so what is the future hold all right new
doctor who lists a couple of things
about this one the first is this is the
first one that the patreon supporters
helped decide on the topic and by that I
mean I actually have a rather lengthy
list of lists that I intend to do
eventually mostly regarding Doctor Who
and I because I try and do them at a
pace of one a month you know I I was
I've got a lot of options for what to do
next so I actually gave a few of those
options out to patreon and they selected
that this month I'm gonna do my pick for
10 actors that I think would be good to
play the doctor now before I get into
these none of these strictly speaking
are wishes I'm not ooh I hope they get
it this is just actors who I thought huh
yeah maybe that could work and now the
other thing that I've tried to do is I
have tried to keep this realistic
because there are actors of a certain I
don't wanna say caliber because it
implies that being popular is also the
same as being a good actor that's not
necessarily the same thing but there's
certain actors who are too high-profile
they just they would never get not for
you know a 13 or even 10 episode series
they you know that's supposed to come
out every year or two years on a regular
schedule they just wouldn't get these
people so you know I think Helen Mirren
would be a fantastic doctor they're
never gonna get her I think in Giselle
book could be very good they're never
gonna get him so I only allowed myself
one sort of one indulgence on the yet
they would never get this person I'm
allowing myself one of those the
restaurant ones who I think actually
fees
at least in terms of the kinds of work
they tend to do might be able to do this
this part in terms of you know just
working the schedule so with that having
been said let's get to it
I've got ten of these I'll start at
number nine and I'll do what in my mind
is kind of the obvious one and I only
say that because I feel like his name
has come up the last few times we knew a
regeneration was imminent and that is
Chris Marshall um now Chris Marshall is
an actor who I know primarily from Love
Actually not exactly his most doctor-ish
role but he does have there is something
quite charming about him and yet at the
same time a little bit off-putting I
mean I don't want to sound mean about it
but the guy who looks a little weird and
actually that's a quality that I kind of
would like to see the doctor have again
cuz I don't I don't think the doctor
like as a person has really looked odd
since Tom Baker and you know they've
tried to make the doctor occasionally
dress odd but I that was a quality that
Tom Baker had cuz you know he had that
wide-eyed kind of wild look and Chris
Marshall has a bit of an odd a bit of a
distinct look to him and I think that
that could that could be something
interesting to play with and I having
looked at you know he's done a lot of a
lot of theater work he's branched out
into drama I think he could be quite
interesting moving on from that oh I
should also mention these are in
absolutely no particular order I'm not
actually like working my way up to a
number one pick so do not take this
ranking as meaning anything so next up
Olivia Colman now back when it we found
out that Capaldi was going to be leaving
and sort of the conversation started
will it be a woman I you know I had my
thoughts about it at the time which you
know eventually you know changed and
evolved and and all that lovely stuff
but certainly one of my early thoughts
was that well if it's gonna be a woman
I think Olivia Colman would be a good
pick and I still think that
she has she has a real intelligence in
her eyes and she's able to communicate
thought processes a very well which i
think is really good for any character
who is supposed to be very intelligent
and who figures who gets through
situations by figuring it out to have an
actor who can you can look at them and
see the wheels turning in the head and
kind of read it on their face and I
think she's quite good for that um I
mean I think she's just a good actress
in general and I I've also seen I have a
really good rapport with a pretty wide
variety of other performers which i
think is also a good thing to have
because you know that it really helps
for the doctor to have good chemistry
with whoever they are sharing the screen
with so after that this one I've
actually mentioned this one before this
one's kind of a holdover from me and one
that I I've given up on thinking this
will ever happen but I still kind of
hope ms Patterson Joseph who's a who has
actually appeared on Doctor Who before
he was in bad wolf and the parting of
the ways he was the guy who faced off
against rose in the weakest link not his
best worker his best role I don't feel
but see I I first saw him in the
Neverwhere BBC miniseries which is okay
he is the highlight of that entire thing
though he played the Marquis de Carabas
and and that character especially the
way he played it was very dr. s Carrie
sort of swish and smooth and you know
fast-talking and in and out of danger
and a little bit flippant but with sort
of this layer of kind of a dark history
a little bit of sadness to him that I
thought was I found immediately
mesmerizing and I've always kind of
wanted to see him play the doctor cuz
because I felt like seeing seeing never
where and seeing him play the Marquita
karabast was like a taste of what he
could have been I wouldn't expect the
character to be exactly like that for
him playing the doctor but I felt like
it was almost a proof of concept to be
like oh I would really
like to see what he would do full-on ahh
but you know what can you do
so moving on from there my fourth one
this this one kind of pushes the limits
of like maybe too big for it except that
he's been doing more television in
recent years so you know why not
Jonathan Pryce um I I have a soft spot
for older doctors it was honestly part
of the reason I really liked Capaldi um
that you know that's not a knock on on
Smith or tenant or Davison or the you
know the younger ones but it's it's rare
to find a young man who can bring that
sense of age and so knowing that you
can't always find that I do kind of lean
towards a rascally older man I think
Jonathan price would be really good for
that I think he and well obviously he
has a Doctor Who connection because he
played the master in the comedy sketch
Doctor Who in the case of the fatal
curse of the fatal death so you know
he's got some association with with
Doctor Who but I think that he because
again he can convey intelligence really
well I mean the the the the whole
subplot of the the sparrows in Game of
Thrones I didn't love but I did love him
as the high Sparrow because he sold that
he sold that charisma and that sincerity
in that earnestness that honest nasarah
needed in order to work and to see him
bring that skill set to the doctor oh
yeah I'd be up for that
so next up I've got one who I'm probably
gonna have to explain who this is
because I suspect most people don't know
going from one of my older options to
one of my younger Luke
Youngblood yeah that is actually that is
actually his real name so actually most
people
watch this channel probably would
remember him if you've seen the first
two Harry Potter movies he appeared in
those he was very young and those so
like the first Harry Potter movie the
kid who's on the mic announcing the
Quidditch game that's Luke Youngblood
now I know him from galavant where he
played Sid the squire who was known for
constantly having a song stepped on by
other characters and for an amazing head
of hair which he absolutely does have
and I think that he would be a really
interesting pick and would bring an
interesting energy because he's vet he
can be very squirrelly very so he's got
a very nervous energy about him and I I
think that he it would be really
interesting to because he's again this
is based off what I saw of him in
galavant but he had this sort of timid
endearing nature where you know he was
kind of it was really interesting to see
because his character was timid that was
like a fair part of his deal but it's a
musical so obviously for the purposes of
song he has to be boisterous and be
charismatic and carry a tune and hold
the camera while at the same time
playing timid and so that kind of
contrast of like a little bit you know
Lee staying back a little bit squirrelly
yet at the same time still commanding
the screen despite that I think that's a
quality I'd be really curious to see
applied to the doctor so next one up
this this one I don't know why I just
think it'd be cool and that's Hugh
Bonneville who has been on Doctor Who
before he played I forget the guys name
he played the pirate in
curse of the black spot but I mean I did
obviously at this point doctor who has
already cast people as the doctor who
have been on the show before and they I
don't think they'd even have to explain
his face the way they did would like
Capaldi because I mean he had this
massive beard when he played the pirate
just shaved the beard it'll be fine
but he's he has he he can come across as
having the weight of the world on his
shoulders in a way that doesn't make it
seem like he's you know he's like trying
to be a martyr about it but he just can
have this sort of sense to him and I
kind of would be interested to see that
sort of almost weariness about the
doctor but like it's not like he's not
like having lost his sense of adventure
but just like oh the university is
saving again okay and and haven't that
kind of thing I feel like I feel like
he'd be good for that and again I also
know I know him from a couple of things
I don't have from Paddington and I also
know him from galavant as well because
he played a pirate he's I've seen him
play a pirate twice actually now that I
think of it maybe I just want the doctor
to be a pirate maybe that's why okay um
so next up Lena Headey best known at
this point as searcy Lannister on Game
of Thrones I've seen her in a few things
Game of Thrones obviously being one I've
seen her in dread she has a fearsome and
frankly frightening energy about her um
but she can't she while she has kind of
become known for playing these very hard
cold characters I you know she is
capable of warmer moments and I but I do
think that sort of Steel enos that oh
wow I really don't ever want to take
this person off be which the doctor
often has but often you don't see it
until you already have ticked ticked
them off
I think would be interesting to sort of
see that element brought a little bit
more to the forefront and you know see
that as more of the initial impression
that the doctor gives as opposed to
being something uncovered in in the heat
of the moment I think yeah I think
something like that could be an
interesting flip where it's the doctors
softness that comes out in in the moment
as opposed to the harshness which is the
way I feel like it's usually been played
certainly a modern ho next up going on
the young end again Ben Whishaw I think
he's just charming I think he's just
charming and endearing and kind of
adorable and I could I could just see
him popping his head out of the TARDIS
door for a peek around I'm not sure I've
got any real solid justification beyond
just like being able to picture it so
well I actually don't know him from all
that much I mean he voices Paddington I
think the only thing I've actually seen
him in might be playing Q on some of the
newer James Bond stuff which he does
quite well and again that does sort of
bring in that element of on being able
to convey intelligence which he does and
he does that well but again I don't know
I can just picture that one that's
that's that's the most justification I
can give it alright we've only got a
couple left and next up I'm gonna talk
about my my freebie that like this is
the one of all the ones on this list I'm
like yeah no way does that ever happen
but it would be really cool tilda
swinton I feel like it would it would
almost kind of be a cool fun sort of
throw in the face of the whole you know
is it better if doctors a man it's a
woman should it go back to cast someone
who has played so many androgynous
character
so well and that's kind of my hope for
her not playing the doctor to play it
very gender neutral or gender flipped
cuz let you know I think of till this
woman I tend to think of of Gabriel from
Constantine I tend to think of Orlando I
tend to think of over even the ancient
one just this sort of mix of a very
masculine and a feminine energy I really
kind of love to see that dual
deliberately poured into the doctor as a
character and just see what people make
of it yeah I think that would be cool
the last one is this one occurred to me
late but then I thought I was like oh
yeah and that is Sean Pertwee yes Jon
Pertwee's son would it be nepotism maybe
I wouldn't care I think partly because I
actually think he would bring a very
different energy to the doctor than his
father did cuz his father was very
dapper very dashing he was a dandy yeah
I mean he was called that flat out in
the show but if you've ever seen
anything with Sean Pertwee he has a very
rough and tumble kind of street-level
cockney ish energy to him I first fell
in love with Sean Pertwee when I saw Dog
Soldiers and but and I mean even his
Alfred on Gotha Alfred the epitome of
the stuck-up British stuffy Butler he
plays with that with that
rough-and-tumble get you know put your
dukes up energy that he just has and
that's not me saying that I think the
dog that if he were to play the doctor
that he should like getting a lot of
fights or anything but I think just
having that more scrappy energy would
not only be really cool but given how
much he also like in the face looks like
his father I think that would just kind
of be really fun to have somebody
kind of looks like the third doctor but
it's very much doing their own thing I
think it would be really cool and fun
and yeah I'll wrap it up there
so those those are my ten actors who I
have no expectation that any of them
ever will play the doctor I'm not saying
place your bets it'll be one of these
nor am i saying I absolutely want these
one of these to be the doctor after it's
not one of these I'll be disappointed
not saying any of that but this is just
kind of a fun exercise so what about you
who do you think would be a good doctor
would be fun in the part would be cool
would be a change of pace whatever you
think whoever you think would be neat to
see or whatever you think about the ones
I put out there drop something down in
the comments let's talk about it a whole
bunch of stuff that you can do because
buttons links one to the patreon any
amount of support is absolutely
appreciated also p.o box and a whole
bunch of other links are all down there
so check out if you want if you don't
that's okay because you know what at the
end of the day you're the council
I'm just running the meetings and until
next time this council is adjourned
[Music]
you
[Applause]
[Music]